who are you I'm see if I can like
talking about myself since when are you
on the Mac I talk dogs to that luckily I
can series the most important new
feature in Mac OS Sierra Apple's new
software coming to your Mac later this
fall
I've been using a Developer Preview for
the last few days and there are a lot of
new features there's picture and picture
for video and tabs and apps but really
Sierra is all about series go to wired
calm
you're not gonna want to use Siri all
time and you're going to feel ridiculous
talking to computer actually you should
feel ridiculous talking to your computer
but still serious more useful than you
might think
for example make the screen brighter
okay this is as bright as it gets
let's way to break it now show me photos
from May 17 to 2015
you too for 10 Cloverfield Lane
so Syria is still Siri which means
sometimes it can be pretty bad who is
Erlich Bachman
yes Civic relationship but even in this
early preview Syria does a lot including
some really cool Mac specific stuff it's
amazing for finding files whether you're
a meticulous organizer or you've never
tagged a file in your entire life
there's still a lot of work left to do
and Siri is still not great but I'm glad
to have it on my back anyway